其他人：这里面居然还有个贴纸
Others: There's actually a sticker in here.
Alice: 哎紫棠你这个耳朵还有吗
Alice: Hey Violet, do you still have this ear?
Alice: 来我也给你贴个
Alice: Come on, let me stick one for you.
Alice: 来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice: 我能给你多贴俩吗
Alice: Can I stick a couple more for you?
其他人：你贴我脑门中间可以吗
Others: Can you stick it in the middle of my forehead?
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
其他人：COS二郎神
Others: You can cosplay as Erlang Shen.
Alice: 玩的就是抽象啊
Alice: We're just playing with abstractions here.
Alice: 我能给你点
Alice: Can I give you some?
其他人：不不不不你怎么拿那么多
Others: No, no, no, why are you taking so many?
Alice: 你这耳朵上贴三个
Alice: You can stick three on your ear.
Alice: 然后中间再贴一个好吗
Alice: And then one in the middle, okay?
Alice: 好的
Alice: Alright.
其他人：OKOK够了够了 够了够了
Others: Okay, okay, that's enough, that's enough.
Alice: 低智游戏
Alice: A low IQ game.
Alice: 现在
Alice: Now.
其他人：我自己来行吗你给我行吗
Others: Can I do it myself, or will you do it for me?
Alice: 不敢想象你贴这个会有多抽象
Alice: I can't imagine how abstract it will look if you stick it yourself.
其他人：恩平常都习惯了
Others: Yeah, I'm used to it.
Alice: 看过延禧攻略吗
Alice: Have you watched "Story of Yanxi Palace"?
Alice: 我也没
Alice: Me neither.
Alice: 但是他那有一二三钱你知道吧
Alice: But there's one, two, three coins in there, you know?
Alice: 给你来一个
Alice: Let me give you one.
其他人：贴正了吗
Others: Is it straight?
Alice: 要不我拿那个睫毛胶给你粘上
Alice: How about I use eyelash glue to stick it on for you?
Alice: 耳朵上
Alice: On your ear.
Alice: 你就贴点大的得了
Alice: Just stick a big one.
其他人：你看过那电影吗
Others: Have you seen that movie?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
Alice: 盗梦空间
Alice: "Inception."
Alice: 你这耳垂好大呀
Alice: Your earlobe is so big.
Alice: 笑晕了
Alice: Laughing to death.
Alice: 笑晕了家人们
Alice: Laughing to death, guys.
Alice: 谁懂啊
Alice: Who understands?
Alice: 我也来俩
Alice: I'll stick two on myself.
Alice: 来来来
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice: 你给我贴俩大小一样的啊
Alice: Stick two of the same size for me.
Alice: 你别给我整一大一小的
Alice: Don't give me one big and one small.
Alice: 看你这歇抽象 低智哈
Alice: Look at you, so abstract and low IQ.
Alice: 怎么捏
Alice: How do you pinch it?
Alice: 贴上了这又贴上了
Alice: Stuck it on, stuck it on again
Alice: 你咋这牛逼呢
Alice: How are you so awesome?
Alice: 你要要不去
Alice: Do you want to go?
其他人：好租比的夸奖女子
Other person: Good job, girl
Alice: 哈哈哈你要不去开个穿耳的之类的
Alice: Hahaha, why don't you go open a piercing shop or something?
Alice: 我觉得你有颇有天赋呢
Alice: I think you have quite a talent
其他人：别搞啊别捧杀我
Other person: Don't flatter me too much
Alice: 来
Alice: Come on
Alice: 看起来不太聪明的样子
Alice: Doesn't look very smart
Alice: 确实看起来不太聪明
Alice: Indeed, doesn't look very smart
Alice: 我要去接
Alice: I need to pick up
Alice: 我接一下我室友
Alice: I need to pick up my roommate
Alice: 走吧一起走 follow me
Alice: Let's go, let's go together, follow me
Alice: 找找
Alice: Look for him
Alice: 定位一下
Alice: Check the location
Alice: 走上那边接他
Alice: Let's go pick him up over there
Alice: OK OK
Alice: 嗨
Alice: Hi
Alice: 这边来吧
Alice: Come over here
Alice: 哎你是不是之前实习的那个呀
Alice: Hey, are you the one who interned before?
Alice: 对啊这不就我室友吗
Alice: Yeah, isn't this my roommate?
Alice: 哦我以为 你不认识了吗
Alice: Oh, I thought you didn't know him
Alice: 我认识 走走走
Alice: I know him, let's go, let's go
其他人：这里是什么地方
Other person: What's this place?
Alice: 确实这就是环球影城附近
Alice: Indeed, this is near Universal Studios
Alice: 他那个搞民宿吧那种
Alice: He runs a B&B or something like that
Alice: 就你来这边玩就可以在这
Alice: So you can stay here when you come to play
Alice: 你觉得是蓝绿色吗
Alice: Do you think it's blue-green?
Alice: 这不是绿色吗
Alice: Isn't it green?
Alice: 绿色吧你说的蓝在哪呢
Alice: It's green, where's the blue you mentioned?
Alice: 蓝 绿
Alice: Blue, green
其他人：所以我开了个蓝开了个绿
Other person: So I got blue and green
Alice: 请进
Alice: Please come in
Alice: 怎么的呢
Alice: What's up?
Alice: 这不是蓝绿色吗
Alice: Isn't this blue-green?
其他人：OKOK
Other person: OK OK
Alice: 这怎么不算蓝绿色呢
Alice: How is this not blue-green?
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Come on
Alice: 请进
Alice: Please come in
Alice: OK OK
Alice: 在做甜点
Alice: Making desserts
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes
Alice: 可以进行一个小游戏
Alice: We can play a little game
Alice: 就是在这个房间里面找到这种贴画
Alice: It's about finding these stickers in this room
Alice: 你看你能找到吗
Alice: See if you can find them
Alice: 呃不带小房间
Alice: Uh, not in the small rooms
Alice: 就是卧室不算
Alice: Bedrooms don't count
其他人：我刚接受完历练
Other: I just finished a trial
其他人：用时大概半个小时
Other: It took about half an hour
Alice: 一共20个
Alice: There are 20 in total
Alice: 她找到了5个
Alice: She found 5
Alice: 你也你找三四个
Alice: You, you found three or four
Alice: 四五个都行
Alice: Four or five is fine
Alice: 给别人留一点
Alice: Leave some for others
Alice: 可以
Alice: Okay
其他人：来请你把二露出来给你来一张
Other: Come on, show your card for a photo
Alice: 真服了又开始拍这种低智小视频了
Alice: I can't believe we're making these dumb little videos again
其他人：哎低智照 片
Other: Yeah, dumb photos
Alice: 行了吗
Alice: Is it done?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice: see
Alice: See
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 先搞点水
Alice: Let's get some water first
Alice: 确实
Alice: Indeed
Alice: 没东西
Alice: Nothing here
Alice: 我干能叫好事吗
Alice: Can what I'm doing be a good thing?
Alice: 肯定不是好事
Alice: Definitely not a good thing
Alice: 好你拍他一下就行了
Alice: Okay, just take a picture of him
其他人：我刚我刚把里面电视关了
Other: I just turned off the TV inside
Alice: 就是你给她打开嘛
Alice: You should turn it on for her
Alice: 不就行了吗
Alice: Wouldn't that work?
Alice: 低智小东西
Alice: Dumb little things
Alice: 抽象
Alice: Abstract
Tasha: 哎呦呦呦
Tasha: Oh wow
其他人：来吧伸手
Other: Come on, reach out
Alice: 她真的很抽象哈哈
Alice: She's really abstract, haha
Alice: 啊不是这个是那种呃类似于这种的
Alice: Ah no, it's more like, uh, something like this
Alice: 地球啊环保这种的
Alice: Earth, environmental protection, that kind of stuff
Alice: 你可以找找
Alice: You can look for it
Alice: 你可以找
Alice: You can find
Alice: 我就我不告诉你
Alice: I won't tell you
Alice: 没关系你可以后面答题
Alice: It's okay, you can answer later
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either
Alice: 不管他了
Alice: Ignore it
其它: 你能你可以
Alice: 我可以啥
Alice: What can I do
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes
Alice: 加油哎不对加错
Alice: Keep going, oh no, wrong way
Alice: 加油加油
Alice: Keep going, keep going
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no
其他人：这是啥呀
Others: What's this
其他人：什么呀
Others: What is it
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this
其他人：看着有点像
Others: It kind of looks like
其他人：天呀好厉害我没有仔细看
Others: Wow, amazing, I didn't look closely
其他人：这里面还有吗
Others: Is there more inside
Tasha: 没有不知道这不是我藏的
Tasha: No, I don't know, I didn't hide it
Alice: 不知道
Alice: I don't know
Alice: 你做好事不留名
Alice: Doing good deeds anonymously
其他人：好人姐
Others: Good person Alice
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: Laughing to death
Alice: 不知道呢哈哈哈
Alice: Don't know, hahaha
其他人：一楼满多的二楼有一点
Others: There's a lot on the first floor and a bit on the second floor
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：大不了一会儿答题吗真是的
Others: You can just answer the questions later, really
其他人：哎他那个答题是必玩环节吗
Others: Hey, is answering the questions a mandatory part
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes
Alice: 哈哈你的知识
Alice: Haha, your knowledge
其他人：我觉得贫瘠尤其环保方面特别贫瘠
Others: I think it's lacking, especially in environmental topics
Alice:那你就瞎猜嘛
Alice: Then just make wild guesses
Alice: 好吧好吧
Alice: Alright, alright
其他人：你让我给你提供灵感 之后你不会没穿内裤得
Others: You're asking me for inspiration? You won't end up not wearing underwear, will you?
Alice: 你至少保证给我对一个好吗
Alice: At least make sure you get one right for me, okay?
Alice: 要不然你怎么赎回我
Alice: Otherwise, how will you redeem me?
其他人：你有什么可说赎
Alice: 什么意思
Alice: What do you mean
其他人：还有什么地方啊
Others: Where else is there
Tasha: 不会有人在卫生间藏着了吧
Tasha: Nobody's hiding in the bathroom, right?
Alice: 嗯不知道呢
Alice: Hmm, I don't know.
其他人：这里我都翻了一遍没有
Others: I checked everywhere here, there's no one.
Alice: 你可以找一些
Alice: You can find some.
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two.
Alice: 没事你找三个也行
Alice: It's fine, you can find three.
Alice: 三四个给别人留一点
Alice: Three or four, leave some for others.
其他人：早知道刚才跟那有一大包我都藏起来就好了
Others: I should have hidden that big bag earlier.
Alice: 你真6啊
Alice: You're so slick.
Alice: 哈哈哈他找着那一包
Alice: Hahaha, he found that bag.
Alice: 然后跟我说这游戏结束了哈哈
Alice: And then told me the game is over, haha.
Alice: 喂你想坐这个是吗
Alice: Hey, you want to sit here?
Alice: 嗯我不让你坐
Alice: Hmm, I won't let you sit.
Alice: 你怎么想
Alice: What do you think?
Alice: 你怎么不看我鞋底下有没呢
Alice: Why don't you check under my shoe?
Alice: 你抬起来我看看啊
Alice: Lift it up, let me see.
Alice: 有我跟你姓好吧
Alice: If there's anything, I'll take your last name.
其他人：袜子呢
Others: What about the socks?
Alice: 来来来来来来
Alice: Come on, come on, come on.
其他人：不不不不不
Others: No, no, no.
Alice:真都假都
Alice: Real or fake?
Alice: 加油加油加油加油
Alice: Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Alice: 说实话我我我藏的我已经忘了
Alice: To be honest, I forgot where I hid mine.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：你可以找一下那个贴纸
Others: You can look for that sticker.
Jake:然后这个相机都不能动
Jake: And the camera can't move.
Jake:别的都欢迎大家
Jake: Everything else is fine.
Alice: 没事你已经找到3个了已经很牛了
Alice: It's okay, you found three, that's impressive.
Jake:哪个相机都不能动
Jake: No camera can move.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oops.
其他人：检查一下袋子万一有呢垃圾袋里面没了
Others: Check the bag, in case there's something in the trash bag.
Alice: 找找找找
Alice: Search, search, search.
其他人：不是真在厕所里藏着吧
Others: Are you sure no one's hiding in the bathroom?
Alice: 不知道呢
Alice: I don't know.
Alice: 啊手套到了
Alice: Ah, found the gloves.
Tasha: 这么明显一个
Tasha: So obvious.
Tasha: 这么半天看不见在哪这呢
Tasha: How come you didn't see it, it's right here.
Alice: 直接偷听
Alice: Just eavesdropping.
Alice: 没事你找到三个了已经不错了
Alice: It's fine, you found three, that's already good.
Alice: 可以给其他嘉宾留点
Alice: Leave some for the other guests.
Alice: 一共20个吧
Alice: A total of 20, right?
Alice: 好了三个不错了
Alice: Alright, three is pretty good.
Alice: 给自己鼓个掌吧
Alice: Let's give ourselves a round of applause.
其他人：都是花一堆出来的吗
Others: Are all these just a bunch of flowers?
Alice: 麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
Alice: 提拉米苏
Alice: Tiramisu.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 给那个摄像头充电
Alice: Charge that camera.
Tasha: 充电宝吗这个吗
Tasha: The power bank, this one?
Alice: 倍儿耐用 没事
Alice: It's super durable, no worries.
Alice: 给我拉张纸
Alice: Pass me a tissue.
Alice: 可以可以
其它人: 那我换一个
Alice: 不错
Alice: 看你小子很有天赋
Alice: You seem pretty talented.
Alice: 在这学两天这应该也会
Alice: Stay here for a couple of days, you'll get it.
Lucia: 这应该也会
Lucia: Yeah, you'll get it.
Alice: 又不收你学费
Alice: And I won't even charge you tuition.
其他人：跟这学两天接来就是我需要把别人骗过来救我
Others: After learning here for a couple of days, I need to trick others into saving me.
Lucia: 哎我觉得我和弦好像弹错了
Lucia: Oh, I think I played the wrong chord.
Tasha: 葫芦娃救爷爷一个一个送是哇
Tasha: Like the story where each gourd doll saves the grandpa one by one.
Tasha: 你看我今天做的那个压花很好看啊
Tasha: Look at the pressed flowers I made today, they look so pretty.
Tasha: 哦我等会还要给他打孔
Tasha: Oh, I still need to punch a hole in it later.
Alice: 看有点像哔哔
Alice: It looks a bit like a beep.
Lucia: 忘了
Lucia: Forgot about it.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
其他人：戴这个镜做东西好像那个贵妇你知道吗那种家里的女主闲着没事自己烤
Others: Wearing these glasses while making stuff, you look like a fancy lady, you know, like a housewife baking at home.
其他人：汤姆猫里的女主人
Others: Like the lady in Tom and Jerry.
其他人：戴的是主人的戒指
Others: Wearing the owner's ring.
Alice:笑死
Alice: So funny.
Lucia: 不是你这鸡蛋
Lucia: Not this egg of yours.
其他人：不是你的戒指戒指在里面鼓包了
Others: No, your ring is inside, making a bump.
Alice: 那有什么办法呢
Alice: What can I do about it?
Alice: 没辙
Alice: No way.